[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt's das wohl
egal ob es so krass dass wir die worte
fehlen
das ist das krasseste rezept er war es
gibt den san sebastian cheesecake was
das ist erkläre ich euch jetzt denn
viele kennen noch gar nicht die den
islam urban candy mit sicherheit da gibt
es einen kaffee da stehen die leute
schlange und ziehen sogar nummern und um
unseren sebastian cheesecake zu kriegen
und wir waren dieses jahr zwei mal in
istanbul
meine zweite ist anreise letztes jahr
2009 10 49 8 kilometer lang bis dann nur
gelaufen haben dieses einzige café wo es
gibt mittlerweile ist bestimmt schon
mehrere entdeckt und haben ihn probiert
und ich füge ich gerne mal die in
stories ein prognostizierter sind sonst
so passieren den beginn sonst haben wir
von hier
april folgte mit der regierung beraten
wir haben den san sebastian cheesecake
gefunden nach fünf 1300 kilometern
wir sind doch nicht alleine diese
theorie sind auch dabei die haben wir
kennen gelernt und ich habe noch nicht
probiert ihre besten gehört was die
anderen sagen und wir waren einfach hin
und weg war richtig lecker hansa zählt
auch ein bisschen weh aber ich muss
nicht sagen du hast ja schon oskar und
der wird eins zu eins gegen eins zu eins
geht also ich habe die augen geschossen
und dachte hey du bist gerade am galata
turm in istanbul in dieser gasse und
probierst den usa den san sebastian
cheesecake freudscher versprecher weil
mein lieblings cheesecake war immer der
new york cheesecake die die mich kennen
die wissen das und jetzt san sebastian
cheesecake hat das einmal getoppt worden
dauerregen so viel war es ein besonderes
video ist einfach und der karl suchen
werden einfach geil so ist es raus ich
habe für euch experimentiert so sieht
das aus wenn ich rezepte entwickler ja
original und ja das ist so weil ich das
immer nebenbei dabei hatte ich habe
immer so ein bisschen nachher doch 1 1 1
die 1 250 gramm betragen
ja ich mache die man selber und ja ich
habe für euch experimentiert und das
sind auch zutaten die bekommt ihr alle
in ganz normalen deutschen supermärkten
hier habe ich doppelt am frischkäse
bitte tut mir eingefallen und kreft
nicht auf die salzigen varianten zurück
nimmt auch keine light variante oder so
doppel raum frischkäse der nicht salzig
schmeckt und den habe ich hier schon in
meiner küchenmaschine da gebe ich jetzt
ganz einfach zucker mit rein und dann
rühren wir das mit dem ruhr haken dann
nehme ich den der gummilippe damit ja
auch die rinder schön mit nimmt ungefähr
10 15 sekunden kleiner tipp von mir
doppel ram frischkäse sowie auch alle
anderen zutaten sollten zimmertemperatur
haben wenn nicht habt ihr so kleine
stückchen von frischkäse der eben nicht
ganz in diese homogene masse ein
da geht und daher am besten auf
zimmertemperatur haben so 10 15 sekunden
sehen wir uns wieder
bitte nicht zu lange hören sonst wird
die mascarpone flüssig das wollen wir
nicht sie darf ruhig noch fest bleiben
und ganz ganz wichtig bei diesem rezept
hier wird nichts auf geschlagen wir
wollen hier keinen luft in die masse
einschlagen damit sie eben so cremig wie
möglich ist jetzt habe ich hier
speisestärke und siebe das noch hin zu
ganz wichtig 7 damit keine klümpchen
dabei sind und ich habe auch die mail
variante für mich ausprobiert hat mir
nicht so gut gefallen bleibt auf jeden
fall lieber bei speisestärke so dass
einmal hinein sieben und auch noch mal
ganz kurz unterrühren
[Musik]
zu dem zimmer war meine habe ich jetzt
aufgeschlagen und einmal ganz kurz
verrührt hier auch ganz ganz wichtig
nicht schlagen kein mixer oder sowas
benutzen um da eben luft rein zu
schlagen weil das ist genau das
gegenteil passieren möchten
und jetzt wo ich das ganz langsam in die
frisch käsemasse ein auf niedriger stufe
und auch nur so lange bis sich die eier
mit dem frischkäse verbunden haben
[Musik]
und wie immer schmecken eier von
glücklichen hühnern die sich frei
bewegen dürfen am allerbesten zum
nächsten schritt gibt ihr den
zitronensaft und die zimmer warme sahne
hinein und außerdem noch vanille extrakt
und das vanille extrakt ist wirklich das
aller aller wichtigste hier am rezept
der mine san sebastian cheesecake ist es
der vanille geschmack der so dominiert
man hat eben auch echt das gefühl man
weiß auch richtige vanille und eben
keine künstlichen aromen daher bitte tut
mir den gefallen und verzichtet auf
vanillin zucker vanillinzucker und hört
schon am namen es heißt noch nicht mal
vanillezucker weil da einfach keine
vanille drin ist also nur aromen dessen
künstliche aromen und das schmeckt man
auch und beim vanille extrakt das
bekommt ihr natürlich hier bei mir im
shop und ist auch alkoholfrei in der
squeeze flasche daher sind wirklich also
da ist echte vanille drinne und das
schmeckt man auch das sieht man auch und
falls ihr den rat nicht da hab' weil ihr
grad ähnlich online bei mir bestellt
habe dann greift solange auf
vanillezucker zurück aber es kommt
natürlich nicht an das extrakt ran
und sobald das alles auch nur ganz kurz
miteinander verrührt wurde ist die masse
auch schon fertig und cannes vorbereitet
werden für den ofen
ich hab mich geschnitten
für kleine wohnungen tun am meisten weh
eine träne verdrücken meine augen glasig
sind nicht wundern
aber jetzt ist alles wieder gut ich weiß
ja was nicht gleich erwartet in san
sebastian cheesecake von daher alles gut
klappt jetzt die 20 cm springform
vorbereitet dann müsst ihr auch darauf
achten dass der boden einmal
ausgekleidet ist und ganz anders als
wenn man anderen rezepten diesmal auch
der rand der springform also da auch
nochmal backpapier drangeben
mit back trend spray oder mit wasser in
so einer sprühflasche könnte selber
entscheiden ich bin back trance pray ist
ein bisschen zuverlässiger er hätte es
auch am rand und das ist ganz wichtig
dass eben nicht ein klappt und jetzt die
skis keck masse einfüllen und dann
backen wir sich sagt euch auch schon die
backzeit ist und diesmal 240 grad umluft
und das ganze dauert in 31 bis maximal
32 minuten und vorher einmal die
springform noch ein paar mal auf dem
boden klopfen das zeige ich euch gleich
aber wenn neben den torschützen ziemlich
laut haben sie damit die bläschen auch
verschwinden
[Musik]
könntest du ja wohl klappen wenn du
willst bist aggressionen rauslassen ja
angegeben und dann einfach auf dem boden
stampfen lassen aber ruhig ein bisschen
mehr bereit das ist die lösung genau die
bläschen verschwinden und das wird noch
cremiger dadurch übrigens braucht ihr
für dieses rezept damit ihr kein frust
erlebt zu hause eine absolut feste
springform wo euch nichts ausläuft meine
verlinke ich euch natürlich gerne in die
infobox genauso wie alle anderen
utensilien zutaten sowieso oder sehen
wir uns nach dem backen wieder
[Musik]
so dass sebastian schiek es fertig ganz
ganz ganz wichtig direkt nach der
backzeit aus dem ofen holen sondern
frage ich euch immer dazu die krise
kuchen drin zu lassen im ofen auskühlen
zu lassen
das dürft ihr hier nicht machen denn
deshalb sebastian cieslik lebt er davon
dass der kern nicht flüssig sondern eher
so richtig zart schmelzend und weich ist
und jetzt müsst ihr ganz stark sein
verspricht ist mir lasst ihn auskühlen
mindestens vier stunden gerne auch über
nacht ich lasse es einfach um abgedeckt
auf zimmertemperatur stehen und wir
sehen uns in vier stündchen wieder
[Musik]
so macht der kühl zeit wird jetzt
einfach der springform rand entfernt
außerdem natürlich auf das backpapier am
rand ansonsten lasse ich den kuchen
jetzt da wo er ist denn ich bin jetzt
ganz ungeduldig ich will diesen san
sebastian es geht jetzt einfach nur
anschneiden um euch die konsistenz zu
zeigen
das messer gleitet richtig nur mal
dieser wirbellosen absolut das ist sogar
ein muss das nein das ist das ist ganz
normal
das richtig toll
genau das ist es genau dass diese
früchte dieser feuchte kern waren
perfekt das ist der san sebastian
cheesecake in perfektion und was sie
jetzt machen müsst schnappt euch einen
teller und legt ihm nicht so drauf
sondern einmal so lecker
[Musik]
und das ist ja der original san
sebastian cheesecake und ich sage euch
auch warum der original ist der san
sebastian thiers gezeichnet sich eben
wie gerade gesagt durch diesen weichen
zart schmelzend man die lehren aus der
schmeckt so ein bisschen wie ganz ganz
zarter vanillepudding also nicht den den
ihr kennen und denen ja antwortet er
dann fest wird sondern einfach richtig
zahl die so aus wollten gemacht haben ja
auf jeden fall ganz ganz wichtig auch
noch zu sagen dass wir backen ja bei
sehr heißer temperatur stoppen dann und
neben ihm ja nach 30 minuten schon raus
was ja unüblich ist aber dadurch haben
wir eben diesen diese harte außenhülle
also hart im sinne von einfach nur fest
also wie ein ganz normaler käsekuchen
erinnert so ein bisschen an den new york
cheesecake und jetzt gehe ich einmal mit
dem löffel rein und oh mein gott das ist
das was ich meine
das ist genau das was ich meine wenn ich
mal für euch natürlich mein gott die
leckerste entdeckung meines ganzen
gesamten letzten jahres also ich bin ja
ein käsekuchen freak und ich habe immer
den us krieg über alles geliebt aber
story der top der tops einfach noch mal
richtig richtig lecker probiert einfach
nur ausdrücklich ist der hat echt
wirklich was verpasst weil ich habe euch
am anfang auch gesagt ich habe mir
einfach so wollt ihr alle
warum wollt ihr allen verbrannten
schieben ich habe den haben wir die
kette warum schicken wir die leute das
und jetzt weiß ich warum und ich bin
einfach nur froh dass ich das nie
entdeckt habt und jetzt müsst ihr das
unbedingt nachmachen haben sie wir
können uns gleich noch in aller ruhe und
ihr macht unbedingt nach ich habe euch
die genauen mengenangaben wie immer in
die infobox geschrieben unbedingt ein
abo da lassen es ist auch komplett
kostenlos also wenn euch dieses video
gefallen hat und wenn ihr mehr solcher
rezepte sehen möchtet beliebte rezepte
sagt einfach ich experimentiere für euch
und macht es für euch nach auf jeden
fall ein abo da lassen genau ich wünsche
euch jetzt ganz viel freude beim
nachbacken und wir sehen uns dann aber
beim nächsten
fifa.com essen los
[Musik]
und in istanbul war es so dass dann
drüber noch geschmolzene schokolade
gegeben wurde also in meinem fall hatte
ich vollmilchschokolade und ich muss
sagen mit der vermischung gerade
zusammen hat's geschmeckt wie ein extrem
geiler kinder regel kuchen und ich
demonstriere ich das mal also wenn dann
richtig dass gut aus jetzt verabschiede
ich nicht aber wirklich also bis bald
schönste
[Musik]